[Music]
sometimes it takes something unusual to
give us a flavor explosion we've been
craving that's why we experiment with
different tastes even if they might seem
extremely off-putting in the first
instance so today we are going to show
you some food ideas that looks terrible
but tastes delicious make sure you stay
to the end to see a breakfast with a
difference if this is your first time
visiting the things then please keep
this video a like and hit that subscribe
button today we are taking a look at 10
food combinations that are gross
but good banana hotdogs do you like hot
dogs we do it's a pretty versatile treat
the combination of frankfurter sausage
and a roll of bread can be absolutely
perfect match them with some ketchup
mustard and maybe even onions you have a
wonderful app however if you go to eat
me or want to really maintain a healthy
lifestyle it may not be ideal but did
you know that you can create a version
of a hotdog that's both vegetarian and
probably healthier the only thing is it
sounds a bit horrible because it's got a
banana in it you might think that the
fruit and the bread wouldn't make a
combination but think about it one of
the chief characteristics of the banana
is that it's soft and mushy so with the
sort of soft roll that you make the
hotdog way it actually works the secret
to this recipe is that it doesn't
tarnish the banana with ketchup let's
face it that would be a bit silly what
it does is use either raspberry or
strawberry squeezy jelly to give a bit
of Zing's in the bananas softer flavor
some people take it to another level
adding in peanut butter and granola to
give some crunch to a pretty soft
textured recipe and others can make it a
bit more colorful by adding some green
kiwi jelly so while it might look odd it
tastes good ice cream covered fries when
we go to a fast food place we like to
have fries with our meal they may not be
the healthiest thing to eat but when
they're warm and fresh then we find it
rather hard to resist them the same
thing goes for an ice cream that's a
real treat to finish off a meal but
eating both at the same time we totally
think twice before doing that but one
person didn't her name is Claudia vuela
and chews swears with tipping french
fries in the McDonald's chocolate sundae
in
yummy women start to think about it our
reservations start to disappear a lot of
ice creams come with wafers right and it
makes a good french fry they're crunchy
and crispy to that word and you might
think that the salt could be an issue
and again the combination of salt and
sweet flavors is rather nice have you
ever had a sea salt in chocolate or
salted caramel it's like that absolutely
delicious so we think that Claudia
really is onto something and of course
it could work with any chocolate ice
cream and any french fry not just the
ones you get a McDonald did you know
that it's been a while since the
McDonald's franchise has had anything to
do with anyone called McDonald's that's
because the company was largely inspired
by a small restaurant an American
businessman Ray Kroc visited back in the
1950s he bought the names and the rest
is history
Marmite pasta there are some things
which split opinion more or less 5050
there are things that you pretty much
kind of have to hold an opinion on you
can't remain neutral you have to get off
the fence in one way or another for
millions of people in the United Kingdom
the thing that splits opinion when it
comes to food is Marmite if you aren't
familiar with it Barney it is a dark on
this black gloopy thing that is usually
spread on bread and toast it usually
comes in a jar and say from yeast and it
has a distinctive salty taste and it is
a subject that has lots of today
anything to company rather cleverly
harness fat when they advertised it with
the slogan you either love it or hate it
we think that the product which is high
in B vitamins is something it's
impossible not to have an opinion on
once you tasted it but either Weil admit
that things got a bit odd when one of
the UK's biggest cooking stars got
involved Nigella Lawson whose recipes
and TV shows made her a household name
in her home country published a Marmite
Hospital recipe the chef said she was
inspired by Italian food writer Anna del
Conte who mentioned it in her memoirs
mikela says there's not much difference
between using Marmite and a stock to it
that may be true but stock won't spark
as many arguments
as marma cheese and jelly one of the
most popular snacks there is is the
peanut butter and jelly sandwich the
Cobell PB&J the staples ocean food so
when you fill in a little bit there's
something about the combination of
flavors really this box however if
you're a gourmet you'll know the joys of
experimenting with cheese
so one smart or possibly brave person
decided that rather than put jelly on
peanut butter he would instead put it on
cheese but not any sort of cheese he
would put it on goat's cheese if you had
to define the biggest difference between
goats cheese and regular cheese made
from cows milk it would be the texture
goat's cheese tends to be a lot softer
than your average cheese which we think
would go well with jelly it would be
easy for the two foods to get mixed up
which would mean it would be easier for
the flavors to combine prepares another
twist this isn't your usual strawberry
or raspberry jelly this is hot pepper
peach jam that in itself has a little
bit of an unusual combination of flavors
like we can get behind a hot pepper
jelly which will give you quite a kick
in the mouth ditto with a peach jelly
put the lovely sweet subtle flavor but
we can imagine would leave you wanting
more and more put the two together with
goats cheese it's tastier than you'd
think
cauliflower popcorn and you go to the
movies what do you like to eat if you're
anything like that from your answer will
be popcorn whether they're the sweet
kind or the sultry variety they are
incredibly moreish and we just love them
here's a fun fact the Native Americans
were the first people to make the stuff
more than three thousand years ago but
it was only in the 1930s that it really
hit the big time corn was cheap to buy
and it was easy to turn into popcorn
when you consider that this was in the
time of the Great Depression and money
was tight whose give it a real boost and
with the popularity of the movies
booming smart cinema owners were able to
sell bags for audiences to munch on
okay so what makes a whole load of fun
to eat Swedish banana pizza
bananas are a pretty versatile fruit
because they have played a subtle flavor
they can be combined with a range of
other delicious goodies and because of
their pulpy texture they can be used as
an ingredient to throw on some think of
a delicious smoothie even though you
most certainly can't taste it there's a
good chance that there's some banana in
there to thicken it out but even we have
to think twice about this next one it's
like sticks of bananas only they've been
put onto a pizza but what you may not
have realized is that mixed in with the
cabbage encouraged like actual spicy
curry the thought of it makes us feel a
little queasy to be honest with you but
actually we'd be very wrong to feel that
way because this food idea actually
works really well it's incredibly
popular in sweden and
very common family snack in the
Scandinavian country it appears to be a
quote spiritual relative of the
controversial Hawaiian pizza we found
that one of the ways to kick off a major
culinary argument is to ask whether
pineapple belongs on a pizza seriously
some people absolutely hate the idea so
the banana which has a much less strong
flavor to it than the pineapple works or
doesn't see much the same thing but we
like it
fish fingers Assessors the world of
science fiction is a wonderful exciting
and inspiring place just like of how
many of today's scientists we're
inspired to take their chosen career
route because of the drama or a book
quite something right however some
foodies also got inspired by style and
they got inspired in a way that to the
uninitiated might seem just a little bit
low we're talking fish fingers custard
okay so in the Doctor Who episodes the
eleventh hour we're introduced to the
eleventh incarnation of the Time Lord to
play by not pip we made em to Amelia
pond a young girl whose fearful TARDIS
crashed and in the English village of
redwoods the doctor who is still a bit
unstable after three generation tries to
find something she likes to use he
doesn't have much luck until he
discovers the bizarre combination of
fish fingers confesses now our chefs
could have done with the doctor that
they were either a sensible or cowardly
what they did instead was to make their
own fish fingers but they didn't use
custard no what they did was to make
their own delicious hollandaise sauce
which kind of looks like custard please
close even so we wish we were brave
enough to take things one step further
and try the doctors original recipes we
can again maybe our stomachs will things
ketchup and dark chocolate the humble
bottle of tomato ketchup is a real icon
of the worldwide kitchen it's versatile
being able to be used as a sauce a dip
or an ingredient it's also famous for
being potentially very hard to get out
of the bottle well that's unless you
need one that comes in a squeezy bottle
that is how does Battle of I'm dough
when you shake the ketchup bottle men
will come and then the lot old something
like that anyway there's one thing that
we don't think any of you have ever
thought about putting ketchup on and
that's dark chocolate probably because
it sounds pretty gross yes it's right
actually you'd be really surprised
because it turns out it's a really
really good idea you see dark chocolate
that's chocolate that's made from cocoa
butter rather than with a milk paste
butter has hints of tomato paste so the
task of us we bring those out and make
some mornings and the other cool thing
is that the foods both contain a
molecule called Lin Elul this explains
why when you smell dark chocolate
there's a hint of coriander and when you
put the chocolate with the ketchup
that's said to become a lot stronger
dark chocolate also known as plain
chocolate is becoming more and more
popular that's because it's seen as
being potentially healthy containing as
it does a high level of antioxidants
12er and white chocolate if you were to
ask you that in a multi that thumbs up
decadent and luxurious then we think the
number one choice at the caveat these
little black colors of salt these
surgeries are synonymous is wealth
glamour and men and as a status night
is expensive to special reserve Osetra
from French caviar thermistor cost $349
for a 30 grand
Kim Wallace 30 prices and the Peter
Chavez famous restaurant the flavors
aficionados of the stuff say you can get
taste ranging from butter to salt to
fish it is said that a good caviar
should contain at least 15 different
flavors and you are going to taste
something different with each bite but
one thing caviar doesn't do is the
pretty the best stuff is black and hog
liquid and when top British chef Heston
Blumenthal combined it with white
chocolate and white - sure so we should
have had faith in the award winning
cookies recipe allows the white
chocolate no leaving a pleasing change
of flavor
Preston's Lima called flagship
restaurant The Fat Duck has won three
Michelin stars and his interest in
science has led him to experiment with
flavors that might seem rather unusual
here's an example snail porridge bacon
and egg ice cream and even personal
cereal for the review though live the
recipes might be off-putting but
one of the best in the business Cheetos
for breakfast at the things we do like a
bowl of good breakfast cereal it's a
combination of crunches at the corner
rice soaks in a bowl of milk that makes
it a perfect way to start today but
somebody took the idea of a crunchy
foodstuff with milk in a whole different
directions when that we think looks
awful for tonight they got a bag of
Cheetos and turn them into a breakfast
cereal he would think that the
combination of cheese flavored corn
would be a bit too it when it was
matched with milk but it would be wrong
it's actually very tasty and it
definitely gives you a new way to kick
start your morning if you don't know
what - those are the bits of corn
covered in the cheese flavor powder
we've been going since 1948 when Charles
owner Doolin hooked them up in Dallas
Texas they were the first snack of their
time - because previously that's where
the thing had clearly been all about
potato chips and after the person who
turned them into a breakfast cereal they
aren't the only person to have had that
sort of idea in 2017 a restaurant so a
meal based on Cheetos opened up in New
York City customers were able to
Cheetos cheesecake Cheetos Fritos sweet
and salty cookies and later on the run
chicken tacos
what snack would you create a menu with
tell us in the comments and that's all
for our 10 food combinations that are
gross but good if you liked it then we
think you should check out 10 times
people absolutely lost the food lottery
thanks for watching and don't forget to
subscribe
[Music]